معنا الان من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه
الناطق باسم جهاز الدفاع المدني في القطاع
الرائد محمود بصله الرائد محمود اهلا بك
يعني الوضع الكارثي في شمال قطاع غزه بات
معلوما منذ عشرات الايام ولكن في هذه
المرحله على ماذا تقتصر
جهودكم نعم هو في الحقيقه لازالت حتى هذه
اللحظه عمليات القصف المستمره من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى منازل المواطنين
في قطاع غزه حتى هذه اللحظه يعني منطقه
جباليا الان تتعرض الى عمليه اباده جماعيه
حقيقه من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وهناك عدد كبير من القذائف الذي يسقط على
رؤوس المواطنين ويسجل هناك حالات كبيره من
الشهداء وحالات من الجرحى التي يعني
تستشهد نتيجه هذه العمليات العسكريه في
هذه المنطقه ولم يقتصر القصف ايضا على
منطقه الشمال فحس بل هناك ايضا في محافظه
غزه ايضا هناك عدد من الاستهداف
ويعني نكاد نجزم ان كل قطاع غزه يتعرض الى
عمليات قصف بشكل مستمر لكن هناك حقيقه
يعني اختلاف في حده هذا القصف والان اكثر
منطقه تتعرض الى عمليات القصف بشكل جنوني
هي منطقه الشمال ومنطقه التفاح والدرج
طبعا جهود الدفاع المدني حتى هذه اللحظه
مستمره فمنذ
الانسحاب لدبابات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والاليات التي كانت متواجده في المناطق في
منطقه فلسطين ومنطقه تل الهواء حينما دخل
طواقم الدفاع المدني الى هذه المناطق
حقيقه هناك يعني شيء جنوني تركته قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه المناطق على
مستوى يعني الشهداء الذين كانوا متواجدين
على الارض هناك اعداد كبيره من الشهداء
الذين كانوا متواجدين واغلب هؤلاء الشهداء
كانوا عباره عن جثث متحلله نتيجه الوقت
الطويل الذي مر عليهم وتحللت اجسادهم في
ظل وجود يعني الاليات الاسرائيليه في هذه
المنطقه حاولنا قدر المستطاع مع المواطنين
انتشال ما يمكن انتشاله من المواطنين
الذين كانوا متواجدين من الشهداء وتم
دفنهم من قبل يعني اقاربهم في المناطق
التي خصصت لذلك وايضا يعني شاهدنا الكثير
من الجثث التي كانت حقيقه يعني دهستها
جرافات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والاليات التي
كانت مساويه للارض نتيجه يعني عمليات
الدهس التي كانت من قبل اليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لهذه الجثث حقيقه كان هناك عدد
كبير من الشهداء متواجد في هذه المنطقه
وايضا هناك حتى هذه اللحظه ناق ايضا في
منطقه تل الهواء لم تصل طواقمنا اليها
نتيجه تواجد الاليات الاسرائيليه في نهايه
شارع ثمانيه في منطقه تل الهواء وهناك
ايضا كما يفيد البعض هناك عدد من الشهداء
لازال متواجد حتى يعني هذه اللحظه في هذه
المناطق ايضا يعني هناك عدد كبير من
الشهداء الذين يعني لازالوا متواجدين تحت
البنايات التي تم استهدافها في مدينه غزه
وفي مدينه الشمال لكن واقع جهاز الدفاع
المدني الان في ظل عمليات الاستهداف
للاليات التي كنا نع عمل فيها والجرافات
والمعدات الثقيله يعني نكاد نقول اننا
حقيقه عملنا الان يقتصر على يعني عمل
بدائي عمل انتشال الشهداء الذين يعني من
السهل يمكن انتشالهم لكن العمل في ظل يعني
نقص المعدات وحقيقه يعني ليس نقول نقص
المعدات بل عدم توفر المعدات نتيجه
الاستهداف المباشر لهذه الاليات الثقيله
يعني نكاد عملنا يقتصر على عمليات انتشال
الشهداء الذين يمكن ان نراهم باعيننا
وايضا الجرحه يتم تحويل الى المشافي التي
ربما نقول انه يعني هناك يعني بوادر خير
لان تكون هناك يعني عمل للمشافي في مدينه
غزه مستشفى الشفاء ومستشفى
المعمداني حقيقه يعني ما شاهدناه ايضا في
من خلال يعني جولاتنا التي قمنا فيها في
المناطق التي خرجت منها قوات الاحتلال
عمليات الاباده وعمليات التخريب للبنيه
التحتيه فعلى كل مستويات مستويات وكل
القطاعات هناك تخريب من قبل الاليات
الاسرائيليه التي حقيقه شلت الكثير من
معالم الحياه في هذه المنطقه ويعني نقول
انه في حال كان هناك عوده الى المواطنين
الذين خرجوا الى مناطق الجنوب اقول ان
اكثر من 80% من المنازل المتواجده في
مناطق تل الهواء والمناطق التي خرجت منها
الاليات الاسرائيليه ربما تكون غير صالحه
للحياه وغير صالحه للسكن نتيجه عدم توفر
المياه وعدم توفر البنيه التحتيه حتى على
مستوى الابار التي كانت متواجده في هذه
المناطق جرفتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ولم تبقي اي شيء من معالم الحياه التي
ربما يعني يستطيع من خلالها ان يعيش
المواطن واليوم نحن حقيقه في الدفاع
المدني يعني ان كان لنا مناشده للعالم
ضروره التدخل الفوري لرد هذا الجهاز
بالمعدات وردف هذا الجهاز بالكوادر
البشريه واحنن حقيقه امس يعني ودعنا احد
يعني ابطال الدفاع المدني الذين تم
استهدافه في منطقه الشاطئ واستشهد وهو احد
يعني زملائنا ليرتفع عدد الشهداء لطواقم
الدفاع المدني في قطاع غزه الى اكثر من 40
شهيد اكثر من 180 ايضا جريح اصيبوا نتيجه
هذه العمليه العسكريه في قطاع غزه يعني
طوال ما فتنا به من معلومات حول الواقع
الذي تواجهون عقب انسحاب بعض القوات
تتابعه للاحتلال من بعض المناطق لم تذكر
وجود ناجين تحت الانقاذ تحاولون انقاذهم
هل بات الامل مفقودا فيما يتعلق بالعثور
على اي من الاشخاص ناجين احياء تحت هذه
الانقاض
وفي الحقيقه في هذه الجزئيه يعني اخراج
المواطنين احياء من تحت الانقاض اعتقد
ربما لن يكون هناك احياء نتيجه ان الوقت
يعني قد تاخر على هؤلاء ونتحدث عن يعني
زمن طويل لكن ان كان هناك يعني اراده
ربانيه لان يكون هناك احياء تحت الانقاض
ربما يعني من الممكن ان يتم اخراجهم لكن
للاسف الشديد لا يوجد اي مقوم من مقومات
العمل التي من خلالها نعمل نحن كطقم دفاع
مدني في غزه من اجل انتشال هؤلاء الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يمنعنا بشكل يعني مؤكد من من
ان نقوم بعمليات انتشال اي احد من
البنايات التي يتم استهدافها وكان هناك
اكثر من عمليه استهداف لطواقم التي تعمل
في المناطق التي يتم استهدافها والمنازل
التي يتم استهدافها من قبل الاحتلال
فحينما تتحرك الطواقم للعمل في هذه
الاماكن يتم استهداف الطواقم حتى يعني
انهم لا يريدوا لنا ان نعمل في قطاع غزه
وفي ايضا في محافظه الشمال ولذلك العمل
محفوف بالمخاطر والعمل يعني خطير جدا في
التعام مع هذا الملف ملف انتشال الشهداء
او انتشال الجرحى او اي احد من من تحت
الانقاض لانه يعتبروا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ملف شائك ولا يريد لنا ان نعمل في هذا
الملف بشكل يعني نهائي كان الله في عونكم
رائد محمود ايضا اريد ان اسالك عن طبيعه
ما شهد تموه في جثامين الشهداء ليست
جميعها كانت نتيجه قصف كان هناك استهداف
وقنص ايضا وفق الكثير من الشهادات
والروايات حدثنا عن هذه الجثث كيف كانت
حالتها من حيث نوعيه الاستهداف التي ادى
بنهايه الامر الى استشهاد
هؤلاء هو في الحقيقه يعني هناك شهادات
الكثير من المواطنين والتقيت انا شخصيا مع
اكثر من عائله حدثو عن عمليات اغتيال او
عمليات قتل متعمد للكثير من العائلات التي
كانت متواجده في منطقه تل الهواء وشاهدنا
تلك الام التي يعني اخبرتنا ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي طلب منها الخروج من المنزل هي
واحد ابنائها وحينما تجاوز ذو امطار قليله
تم استهدافهم باحد القناصين الذين كانوا
متواجدين في البنايه واصيبت المراه واصيب
ايضا طفلها وحدثت ايضا يعني اخت هذه
المراه على ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قام
باعدام ع افراد من هذه العائله بشكل مباشر
وتم تصفيتهم بشكل مباشر وحينما تحركت
الطواقم الى يعني هذا المكان بعد الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي من هذه المنطقه بالفعل وجدنا
عدد من الجثث اطلاق نار مباشر على رؤوسهم
ومن مسافه قريبه وهذا ي دلل على ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ارتكب عمليات قتل
متعمد وعمليات اعدام مباشره للمواطنين
ايضا كان هناك عدد من الاصابات الذين
كانوا متواجدين في منطقه الهواء تل الهواء
تم استهدافهم من القناص الاسرائيلي وتركهم
لساعات طويله ينزفون حتى يعني استشهدوا
وايضا من هذه الحالات يعني شاهدنا احد
الرجال الكبار في السن الذي كان متواجد في
منطقه تل الهواء ايضا تم اطلاق النار على
قدميه وترك لمده طويله وحينما حاول احد
المواطنين الاقتراب من هذا المكان ايضا
قام الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باطلاق النار
وكان الاحتلال يعني يتعمد بعمليات القتل
المباشر وعمليات الاستهداف المباشر حتى
يعني يمنع من اي احد ان يتقدم من اجل
انقاذ اي مواطن يتم يعني قنصه من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا في قضيه يعني
القضيه الغريبه حقيقه والتي يعني ربما
نقول اننا في هذه الحرب نشاهدها يعني لم
نشاهدها من قبل لكن شاهدناها في هذه الحرب
الدمويه عمليه دهس المواطنين بالاليات
الاسرائيليه والجرافات الاسرائيليه حيث
شاهدنا الجثث متساويه في الارض ولا اقول
يعني ان هناك جثه واحده بل هناك جثث يعني
بشكل كبير جدا كانت يعني تم دهسها من قبل
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في منطقه تل
الهواء وهناك حتى هذه اللحظه يعني عدد من
الجثث لازال متواجد حتى هذه اللحظه ولا
يمكن حقيقه التعرف على هؤلاء المواطنين
فيعني تقوم طواقمنا بعمليات الدفن
ربما نقول انهم مجهولين او مجهول التعرف
عليهم من قبل عوائلهم وهناك عدد من
المواطنين ايضا يحاول قدر المستطاع ان
يبحث عن عوائلهم او يبحثوا عن ابنائهم لكن
للاسف الشديد نتيجه الاستهدافات العنيفه
ونتيجه عمليات التفحم وعمليات البتر
الكثيره في الجثث التي متوا التي كانت
متواجده على الارض يعني هناك صعوبه من قبل
الاهالي من التعرف على مواطنيهم او
اقاربهم ولذلك حقيقه يعني ما شاهدناه نحن
في الدف الفاع المدني في هذه الحرب هو شيء
يعني خارج عن الخيال وهو شيء جنوني لم
نشاهده من قبل وهذا يستدعي على ان العالم
يجب ان يعلم ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يرتكب
في قطاع غزه مجازر ضد الانسانيه ويرتكب
مجازر قتل عمد ويرتكب مجازر اباده جماعيه
بحق المدنيين وبحق المواطنين العزل
المتواجدين في قطاع غزه ايضا يعني نهيك عن
قضيه القتل المباشر للمواطنين بعدم توفر
كل مقومات الحياه التي منعتها اسرائيل من
الدخول ال الى قطاع غزه واليوم هناك
معاناه كبيره يعانيها المواطن الغزي في في
محافظه غزه ومحافظه الشمال خصوصا في قضيه
عدم توفر الماء وعدم توفر الغذاء وهذا
حقيقه يعني يسبب مجاعه في قطاع غزه وايضا
قضيه الامراض المنتشره ايضا هنا يعني
حالات التكدس الكبيره يعني نتحدث في منطقه
الشفاء لوحدها هناك عدد ضخم من المواطنين
الذين نزحوا من منازلهم الى هذا المكان
ليحتموا من يعني من من قذائف الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ومن استهدافات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي لم تتوقف وخصوصا في وقت
المساء يقوم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باطلاق
حمم القذائف بشكل كبير جدا على منازل
المواطنين وكل عمليه استهداف للاسف الشديد
تخلف اما شهداء واما جرحى اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه
الناطق باسم جهاز الدفاع المدني في قطاع
غزه الرائد محمود بص